the way forward on Capitol Hill with the
impeachment inquiry is clouded with
unknowns we've been saying that for days
but possible delays including witnesses
failing to show up legal fights and
partisan showdowns plus party leaders
are weighing the political implications
ahead of the 2020 election chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
looks at the impeachment calendar ahead
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi says she
expects public hearings to begin this
month but tells Bloomberg News there is
no deadline to finish we think The Times
have found us what the president has
done is to say the three separate and
co-equal branches of government forget
that article two it's about me I can do
that but House leaders have not yet
released a calendar for public hearings
and an eventual vote on recommending
articles of impeachment for now the
majority is mom I can't answer that
question yet internal discussions of a
timeline continue taking shape while the
House is on recess next week there will
be more closed-door depositions
including Thursday scheduled session
with former national security advisor
John Bolton but his lawyers say he may
not appear sources tell Fox News no
subpoena has been issued yet some
members hope several weeks of public
hearings would follow first in the
Intelligence Committee then judiciary
and could be wrapped up sometime in
December after intelligence releases
it's investigatory findings in judiciary
lawyers for president Trump would also
be allowed to question witnesses and
present additional evidence if it goes
to the Judiciary Committee the Chairman
still has full discretion to deny to
veto witnesses veto power by the
Chairman after committee vote on
recommending articles of impeachment the
full house would decide if passed the
matter then goes to the Senate for a
trial which could be held as early as
January overly optimistic in the eyes of
many on the hill
I hope the presidency has not been
harmed Bill Clinton's 1998 trial lasted
five weeks that puts any Trump trial
perhaps ending around the first 2020
presidential caucuses and primaries in
February the wild-card is a protracted
court fight with the White House and
individual witnesses challenging how
subpoenas and Democrats also fear any
delay tactics by Republicans could drag
the process on indefinitely
another complication Pelosi hinted the
house probe could go beyond the
president's Ukraine call she notes
eleven obstruction of justice provisions
in the Muller report Pelosi says perhaps
some of them will be part of this